does it make it easier for you to have
love interest because no girlfriend is
an actress who she understands a little
bit that was a nice little segue well my
new girlfriend we're still finding our
way so it's it's brand-new so you must
be talking about Annabelle Acosta we're
brand new I mean we just played kissy
face like that's it no like that's it so
they'd open they're not getting married
and there's no little babies running
around we're still brand new like first
base like you know so and and I've
learned that in life just through prior
relationships like let's just have some
fun and take baby steps so you know so
you know it's just the world and I don't
say the world is talking about but
people know because I went to the
Grammys with a beautiful lady but it's
just that it was just like hi nice to
meet you I like what I see you like what
you see let's get to know each other
over coffee and I happen to have tickets
to the Grammys and that's how that
happened it just and it was a great day
but it's but it's like it's kind of
backwards though it's like yeah we went
big before we like even knew each
other's last name you know or what kind
of cat or dog each other you know but no
it's it's fun but it's a it's baby steps
so who knows it's just but it it is
weird when you're in relationships or or
have a sweetheart or you're your
opposite actor the actress has a fiance
a man of words so you know you if
there's TV kissing and then there's just
general it's like it to be with an actor
or an actress you have to know that
that's what they do for a living so for
me for a woman in my life you got it
there's got to be a lot of trust and
then and she's got to trust me and I got
to make sure that she knows that I got
her back but what I do for a living
means that I one of the perks or one of
the job requirements is I get to play
kissy-face a little bit but it's it's
you keep you keep the real stuff you
keep the emotion of it all and you keep
that a little extra hanky-panky you keep
that for you your boo at home but yeah
I'll set but it but everybody thinks
that like oh you get to kiss this pretty
girl are you gonna do a love scene and
you're gonna do all that oh there's like
50 people standing around staring at you
and there's cameras everywhere and
there's lights everywhere so it's not
it's not very sexy our job is to make it
look sexy but it's not very it's cold
you know you got these funny little
underwear on and you know and this is
you good and it's just it's all awkward
and weird and then you have to do it
like 16 different ways and then you have
to like make sure you're doing it just
right for the camera and her hair is out
of her face and then gotta use my hand
to cover you know certain body parts and
so yeah it's like it's this awkward
little dance that you guys yeah so you
have to make it look oh it's a sexy home
you know and you don't want to use too
much tongue because that's weird on
camera or no tongue because her
boyfriend might be real big you know you
know it's just so it's it's it's it's
not what people think it is when it
comes to shooting it I just can't
believe you also say first base I
thought you only hit on we're all
swinging for the fences I'm gonna live
but my mama raised a gentleman first my
mama raised a gentleman but you know at
the end of the day we're all trying to
we're all trying to go everybody wants
to get back in there birthday soon let's
just keep it 100 it seems like it would
still having a great time obviously yeah
you know back how do you ensure and kind
of instill that morality we got a great
thing going I mean we're tired I'm not
gonna not just me I'm tired I'm tired
being hondo being the lead I'm very
proud to be the lead but I'm also humble
enough and smart enough to know that you
know even though I'm number one and a
Call Sheet oh I'm the lead I'm very
proud of that because I I spend a lot of
this a lot of years in the game getting
here but I'm humble enough was smart
enough to know I can't do it alone
I need my team I need my cast I need the
writers I need the crew I'm more proud
to be the leader and in being a leader
it's important to me to take this job
take this opportunity and take to the
take the people that are a part of it
very seriously so I'm about getting the
work done I want because I want the show
to be special I don't want to just be
good I don't want to be ordinary I want
it to be special I want it to be talked
about I don't let's aim for great I want
to be unique but I also want to have a
lot of fun and and so for my time in the
game I've seen a lot of good and then
I've seen a lot of BS I've seen a lot of
like not so good and I've seen bad
personalities bad situations politics
because it's a business and it's a
ruthless it's a ruthless business but
when you have when you bless and have
the opportunity or
right to be in this business let's take
care of business but let's have some fun
let's get to know each other let's play
jokes on each other let's let's play
football throw footballs in the air
let's race each other you know let's
let's let's you know whatever yes oh
yeah everybody not just the cast the
crew everybody know one of the cameramen
his name is Tim like I told him I said
look I'm 47 years old and about to be 48
Hondo is 35 so I got to paint the greys
and I got to get in the gym I got a
stretch but I'm doing all this physical
Hondo stuff and and but you don't see
his Hondo's a bad man but Shamar is like
crippled walking around his house I'd do
an epson salt and all this other stuff
but you know I got a little ego and all
that but one of the cameramen his name's
Tim so I told him on the last day of
shooting at this season we're gonna have
a 50-yard footrace and the reason I have
to do it on the last day of the season
is because my 47 year old ass I might
pull a hamstring so I'm trying to I'm
trying to get in shape and he's only 26
and I said look and it's the the the
last day of the season is the day before
my 48th birthday I said just know if you
lose you just lost to an old-ass man you
know if he wins he gets to say I beat
the main guy in our show I beat you more
okay more more he's gonna run his mouth
if I win I got a big mouth and I got
microphones and cameras and and I'm 48
and I'm gonna talk about I will not shut
up I'm gonna be you lost to an old man I
said but you got to race me in season
one you can't raise me in a season five
season you know I'm trying to keep my
black from cracking on camera I'm a bad
dude from action to cut but at home I
got I mean I got ice bags I got epson
salt
I got Advil somebody hug me I need a
massage mention
seasons are you already having the talks
about season two I'm an optimistic do
you know I mean I mean call it ego if
you want to but it's just you know when
I put my mind to something and again I
can't do it by myself and nothing's
guaranteed but I just I don't fail and
so we have to follow the business and
CBS and Sony have to make a decision but
you know ten million viewers a week
consistently and and we're in 200 and
something countries you always got
butterflies I mean not you can never
take anything for granted but I just I'm
not confident optimistic do but the fans
have come through my baby girls homies
and fans they've been so loyal the rest
of the cast they've got following and
you know the numbers are speaking for
itself and and it's a good show the
writing is good I mean all starts with
the writing I mean I can be as fabulous
as I think I am but if there's no
writing then there's nothing for us to
portray there's nothing so you got to
feel the show you can't just see the
show you can't just see me see us you
got to feel the show and I'm having a
lot of fun because because this version
of SWAT is not imitating the movie from
16 years ago it's not imitating the TV
show from the 70s it's the same theme
song and uh and it's it's it's the name
SWAT but it's it's today's SWAT it's
2017-2018 and beyond SWAT it's the Trump
years without talking about Trump it's
it's not a political show but we're
talking about social and racial issues
in this country and around the world you
know so it's it's a very entertaining
show the first thing SWAT is it's a good
time but we've got these poignant
messages we're talking about black lives
matter we're talking about human
trafficking we're talking about domestic
terrorists and we're talking about
cyberbullying I mean there's all these
topics but we don't preach to you we
don't hit you overhead you watch the
news there's there's a lot of crap going
on there's a lot of there's a lot of
dissension there's a lot of fear there's
a lot of division and so is a TV show
gonna fix that no but we're shedding
light on it has it I think we can but I
don't think I just want to say that I
don't think a TV show can fix the
problems of the world but I think if we
can start a start if we can start a
dialogue if we can create some patience
if we can create a little more
understanding if we can we kind of tempt
or challenge people to dig beneath the
surface see past color talk to each
other before we judge each other
you get that from this show but but you
but you get it in a very entertaining
way we entertain you we thrill you
we do cool cop stuff but it's all based
in real life stuff that might stick with
you and make you think